allez on passe tout de suite au focus
cette semaine on va parler de la plus
grande star française actuelle Mylène
Farmer je sais que vous êtes tous fan
[Musique]
S
comme ça après des années d'absence
Mylène Farmer vient de repartir en
tournée depuis le 3 juin dernier de
parisien à profiter pour revenir sur sa
carrière en donnant la parole à ses
proches et notamment à son ex-compagnon
Laurent de Tana bien sûr on regarde un
recap on en parle après
[Musique]
Mylène Farmer et sans aucun doute l'une
des superstars les plus secrètes de la
planète
[Applaudissements]
ce mystère et cette différence la
chanteuse les cultive depuis ses débuts
dans les années 80
maman
et 40 ans après en pleine tournée des
stades intitulés never more l'artiste
toujours aussi mystérieuse a déjà
enflammé les villes de Lille et de
Nantes
cette tournée XXL nécessite pas moins de
90 semi-remorque 900 tonnes de matériel
et 1000 personnes du jamais vu en France
mais rien n'est trop beau pour les fans
de la chanteuse
qui lui vaut un culte presque mystique
sans savoir grand chose de leur idole
j'en suis consciente et j'en suis
heureuse néanmoins dernièrement son
ex-compagnon est producteur Laurent
Boutonnat a fait des confidences
étonnantes sur la star et leur relation
de quoi éclaircir un tout petit peu le
mystère
[Applaudissements]
sur la grande Mylène Farmer juste une
question de poser une question mais vous
ne répondez pas dites-moi qui est fan de
Mylène Farmer là on vous répond pas vous
levez la main ou pas
rien visiblement chez vous oui
pas toi
[Musique]
alors attends je commence par nous
Ludivine non
parce que je l'aime bien et puis elle me
rappelle mon enfance et puis c'est une
femme c'était une des féministes pour
moi avant-gardiste quand j'étais petite
qui faisait des choses que personne
d'autre nos affaires maintenant c'est
vrai que son petit côté mystique Miss
cercueil mi truc ouais en fait ça ça me
fait un peu flipper mais je reste très
admirative évidemment de la personne
je suis absolument fasciné par la par la
longe par la longévité dans un univers
hostile on va dire par de ne rien aux
femmes et elle réussit à imposer un
personnage un univers et alors ça pour
ça bravo
moi je suis fan de déjà depuis tout
début c'est clips c'est que les vidéos
étaient des vrais films oui donc ça
c'est ce qui nous a plongé dans ces
clips et dans son histoire après on
connaît pas grand-chose de la personne
parce que c'est ouais mais du coup
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ça lui porte pas
préjudice peut-être pour pour vendre
plus de place non alors tu vois à
l'époque Odon elle est la plus de 500000
c'est elle était entrée Mauroy à Lille
la semaine dernière
avec ma radio nous sommes partenaires je
peux te dire on me demande des places
tous les jours c'est complet partout
alors
et alors il y a eu plus de 500000 passes
devant lui qu'est-ce qu'il y a Francesca
on en a pas beaucoup de très très
grandes stars en France elle elle fait
quand même partie de l'élite évidemment
des États-Unis ils ont Beyoncé c'est sûr
c'est plus mod et tout ça mais nous
Mylène Farmer c'est la vraie grande star
moi je me rappelle que petit je
regardais ses clips en cachette et je me
faisais défoncer derrière parce que tu
regardes c'est des cochonneries mais
mais voyez ce qui est intéressant chez
Mylène Farmer c'est que elle ne fait
plus d'interview je suis bien placé pour
le savoir il fait plus d'interview du
tout depuis déjà de nombreuses années la
dernière fois on a pu l'interviewer
c'était dans les années 80-90 et encore
c'était très difficile tout état de
conviction elle a jamais aimé
l'interview en elle-même elle dit que
s'exprime par les chansons pas son
univers etc
c'est une des seuls artistes quand même
qui n'a pas besoin de faire de promotion
à la fois pour vendre ses albums et à la
fois pour remplir ces stades et la folie
[Rires]
elle est excellente en interview elle
est très très drôle quand elle veut mais
elle est remarques intelligentes
forcément cette fille tu vois cette
carrière qu'elle a cette rigueur alors
moi je peux vous faire une petite
confidence parce que je la vois souvent
et je peux vous dire votre restaurant ça
et ta mère faut pas le dire
parce qu'elle fait de la gym tous les
jours on a une rigueur de vie
extraordinaire elle sort du restaurant
elle s'allume
normalement
je peux vous dire qu'elle est
extrêmement les gens imaginent c'est
Mylène Farmer caché oui elle est
discrète c'est sûr c'est une femme
élégante et discrète mais elle dit
bonjour aux gens elle parle à tout le
monde à l'état
j'ai connu d'autres stars qui est pas du
tout elle a une vie normale et un
contact normal avec les gens je peux
vous dire voilà
je pense qu'elle a le je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué par contre j'ai buggé
mais tous ces fans en général sont des
hommes et en fait je pense que c'est un
peu le fantasme de la
Larousse un peu ingénue comme ça je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que c'est ce que
vous voulez pas normal j'aime beaucoup
je connais ces chansons
je suis pas sensible à sa musique
maintenant je suis d'accord avec
Francesca je reconnais qu'elle a cette
musique ne touche pas mais par contre
c'est vrai que c'est notre Madonna à
nous quoi c'est à dire que ce soit assez
spectacles particulièrement ces
spectacles mais aussi c'est clips c'est
exceptionnel c'est une grande star à ce
niveau là après la première chanson les
paroles de ces chansons ne me touchent
pas justement quand tu dis quand tu dis
personne personne la connaît vraiment
cette part de mystère est-ce que vous
trouvez ça bien ou pas Sophie
un petit peu comme en fait c'est c'est
la reine des concerts un peu comme
Indochine et elle a ce côté un peu comme
Nicolas Sirkis aussi qui donne très peu
d'interviews qui est un type qui est
extrêmement génial moi j'ai eu la chance
de l'interviewer qui lit de la poésie
des Sylvia place et compagnie elle c'est
pareil c'est une femme qui est
extrêmement cultivée très vite très très
littéraire et je trouve que le public ne
s'y trompe pas et justement elle a pas
un public de décérébré comme on peut
penser de temps en temps ou comme on
peut penser pour Indochine elle a un
public justement assez fin elle a aussi
le public un peu tout le public des gays
parce que tu dis voilà elle nous plaît
beaucoup aux hommes en fait elle plaît
beaucoup aussi aux homos et elle a ce
public assez voilà sensible fin poétique
et moi je trouve que c'est un vrai génie
cette meuf là à savoir sur la grande
Mylène Farmer mesdames messieurs
elle a demandé à ne plus être nommé au
NRJ MUSIC
Pascal gagner tous les ans
c'est plutôt extrêmement élégant elle a
dit je laisse la place à gagner tous les
ans c'est formidable qui fait ça dans le
métier désolé personne c'est laquelle
récupérer ouais mais là oui bah oui elle
vit avec un singe vous le savez un petit
cadeau
elle a des chiens blancs
je suis célibataire je vis avec un
capucin qui n'est pas un moine mais un
petit singe au cas où Brigitte Macron
est fan de Mylène Farmer
comme son double ah ouais Johnny
Hallyday le grand Johnny d'ailleurs non
c'était l'anniversaire de cette semaine
il dit que c'était l'une des seules qui
pouvait faire des shows comme lui à peu
près et puis Laetitia qui l'a confirmé
d'ailleurs sur le JT de absolument
l'équivalent de femmes françaises qui a
fait le Stade de France oui c'est énorme
6 fois
elle arrête pas elle arrête pas voilà
alors ben c'est bien voilà j'ai tout dit
Johnny disait que c'était la seule à
pouvoir rivaliser avec lui au niveau
scénique c'est une bête de scène et je
peux vous dire que son nouveau spectacle
il est extraordinaire qui va aller la
voir moi est-ce que vous avez des sous
mais nous qui avons pas trop de chance